on l'oublié parfois mais la crise
sanitaire de la coved 19 vient s'ajouter
à une autre crise déjà présente sur la
planète
la crise alimentaire même dans un pays
riche comme le canada les demandes pour
de l'aide alimentaire ont explosé depuis
mars
alors comment se fait-il qu'avec toute
la nourriture produite et même gaspillé
dans le monde autant de gens ne mangent
pas à leur faim
certains sont d'avis que cette crise est
peut-être l'occasion de revoir le
commerce mondial et notre système
alimentaire
[Musique]
jamais les aliments n'ont autant voyagé
sur la planète
depuis que les produits agricoles font
partie des accords internationaux de
commerce
la valeur des aliments exportée dans le
monde a explosé
elle atteint la somme astronomique de
1800 milliards de dollars américains par
année
[Musique]
mais ce système alimentaire mondialisée
repose sur des frontières ouvertes et
sur une agriculture qui fonctionne à
plein régime
[Musique]
qu'arrive-t-il quand un virus stop
l'économie qu'il confine la moitié des
humains de la planète
la capacité des peuples à se nourrir
serait-elle devenue trop dépendante du
commerce mondial cet homme en est
convaincu l'alimentation n'est pas une
marchandise comme une autre
faut faire très attention à ça
jean-louis rastoin et membre de
l'académie d'agriculture de france et
fondateur de la chaire alimentation du
monde de l'unesco
il affirme que notre système alimentaire
mondialisé en maintenant atteint sa
limite
la pandémie de covin 19 nous a révélé
les faiblesses du commerce mondial de
nos aliments faut espérer que des crises
comme la copie de 19 déclenché quelque
part un signal d'alarmé et disent
attention
covin nineteen knb tracteur eye ase
pandemic 11 mars 2020 l'om s annonce que
lakovic n'a fait une pandémie les
conséquences sur le commerce
agroalimentaire se font rapidement
sentir pour les pays qui ont misé des
pans entiers de leur agriculture sur
l'exportation
c'est la catastrophe
aux etats-unis par exemple on a dû jeter
des milliers de litres de lait faute
d'acheteur
cette pandémie révélera aussi la
fragilité des usines de transformation
souvent orientées vers l'exportation
le confinement de ces travailleurs aura
des répercussions sur toute la chaîne de
production
donc quand vous diminuez la capacité de
production deux par deux dans les usines
laitières ou les usines de bétail et
bien évidemment vous perdez toute cette
matière première
vous avez vu ce qu'on a fait aux états
unis en france aussi en europe on a jeté
des milliers de litres de lait etc
ça fait mal au coeur évidemment c'est
insupportable du point de vue de morale
jean-louis rastoin rappelle que l'essor
fulgurant du commerce agroalimentaire
s'est fait en partie grâce aux
travailleurs étrangers
la libre circulation des travailleurs
entre les pays est nécessaire mais quand
la pandémie éclater les fermes
canadiennes accuse un déficit de 50
mille travailleurs étrangers
cette pénurie sera tout aussi importante
en europe là où ça va pas c'est que peu
pour ramasser les fraises des abricots
les pêches et les pommes et les poires
et cetera on ait recours quasi
exclusivement je pense à la france un
hadj à main d'oeuvre étrangère
ce ce sacre est une très grande
dépendance dont des quais un accident du
type qu'ovide et bien les travailleurs
ne viennent plus et on a perdu des
milliers sinon des centaines de milliers
de tonnes de produits frais fruits et
légumes à cause de ça
la pandémie ne fera pas tout le monde
également
l'onu avertit que le nombre de personnes
souffrant de la faim dans le monde
pourrait doubler en raison de la coved
si la sphère de multiples causes
l'agroéconomiste français affirment que
le commerce international fait aussi
partie du problème
ce qu'on peut tout d'abord incriminé
dans cette mondialisation c'est une
dépendance des pays importateurs pour
certaines denrées dites stratégiques
si vous êtes en asie vous avez besoin de
riz pour survivre si vous êtes en europe
ou rouen en amérique vous avez besoin de
blé et de maïs
donc ce ça ce sont des produits
absolument indispensables à la vie et il
est préférable d'essayer de les produire
sur son sol dans son pays que de les
importer
mais les subventions qu'accor les pays
riches à leurs producteurs agricoles ont
permis aux pays pauvres d'importer leurs
aliments à bas prix or en temps de crise
le prix des denrées monte en flèche
ce qui expose au grand jour la
dépendance de bien des pays
[Musique]
le chercheur donne comme exemple le
poulet congelé
le brésil et les états unis réussissent
à exporter leurs poulets à un prix qui
défient toute concurrence
seulement 1 dollar le kilo lorsque ça
arrive au burkina faso lorsque ça arrive
au bénin lorsque ça arrive en bolivie
etc dans des pays pauvres
eh bien ça va assécher si je puis dire
où ça va détruire complètement la
production locale parce que la
production locale
elle est faite avec des petits ateliers
d'élevage les petit atelier d'abattage
etc et donc on ne pourra pas entrer en
compétition avec des pays qui ont des
usines énorme des abattoirs énorme et
cetera c'est pas possible
jean-louis rastoin affirment que la
mondialisation n'est pas responsable de
tous les maux l'agriculture
d'industrialiser sur laquelle repose ce
commerce à nourrir une population
mondiale en pleine croissance
mais ce commerce a mis les agricultures
du monde entier en concurrence la
recherche de profits qui en découlent a
pavé la voie à la concentration
d'entreprises ce qui a fait naître des
géants de l'agroalimentaire un exemple
il ne reste aujourd'hui qu'une
demi-douzaine de multinationales de
l'agrochimie qui contrôlent le commerce
des semences et des pesticides
[Musique]
et à l'autre bout de la chaîne
agroalimentaire la situation n'est guère
mieux
en france vous avez une seule centrale
d'achat qui réunit deux grands
distributeurs qui fait 40% des achats
alimentaires
c'est énorme donc cette concentration
elle fait pression d'abord sur les
industriels et les industriels qui
disent oui mais la grande distribution
pour mâcher mes produits
elle veut que ce soit moins cher donc
vos agriculteurs je vous achète moins
cher et c'est pas du tout équilibrées
pour chaque dollar dépensé par le
consommateur l'agriculteur américain ne
touche que 7,7 secondes c'est 200 de
moins qu'il ya dix ans donc non
seulement c'est cesser très faible mais
ça a baissé pour le spécialiste
notre système alimentaire mondialisée
n'est plus durable
il est responsable à lui seul de 30% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de la
planète
c'est énorme maintenant on atteint des
limites en 2020 et les agronomes le
reconnaissent les sols sont épuisés
on a dégradé les terres on a pollué les
nappes phréatiques et c'est donc il faut
aller vers un système que l'on pourrait
qualifier de plus autonome et plus
économes
peut-on changer la production et le
commerce de nos aliments
le chercheur en est convaincu la coved
19 à montrer la résilience d'une
agriculture qui réduit les
intermédiaires et qui mise sur les
circuits courts ayant comme objectif
l'autonomie alimentaire régionale autant
que faire se peut
[Musique]
l'agroéconomiste ne prône pas au retour
à l'autosuffisance d'autrefois la
mondialisation permettra toujours de
combler ce qu'un pays ne peut produire
mais au commerce international
il faut maintenant ajouter d agriculture
régionale et nationale
ce système alimentaire territorialisée
dit il or l avantage de diversifier
l'agriculture et de ramener des emplois
en région
dans le monde entier c'est l'exode rural
généraliser les campagnes se vident et
deviennent des déserts humains et les
villes se remplissent on peut imaginer
d'ailleurs que la suite de l'aco vide là
il ya une migration on en parle on dit
que paris va perdre deux cent mille
habitants dans les mois à venir pourquoi
parce que les gens prennent conscience
de ça ils vont s'établir dans des zones
rurales
[Musique]
à terme il faut aussi réformer les
accords de commerce de plus en plus de
voix se font entendre pour intégrer aux
accords internationaux la protection de
l'environnement et la sécurité
alimentaire des peuples
pour jean-louis rastoin lakovic 19 nous
rappelle que la recherche d'aliments au
plus bas coût a maintenant atteint ses
limites
la nourriture est bien c'est un bien
commun de l'humanité
alors évidemment il faut le conserver
dans des règles économiques aussi il
faut que les marchés soient là et cetera
mais complétons les marchés en mettant
sur le même pied le profit économique la
protection d'environnement et surtout
l'équité sociale les droits humains
[Musique]
non